meanwhile holders predictably
backtracking tweeting quote okay stop
the fake outrage I'm obviously not
advocating violence in fact when I was
AG violent crime in the US was
historically low I'm saying Republicans
are undermining our democracy and
Democrats need to be tough proud and
stand up for the values we believe in
the end all right data what are the
things that really works in politics is
when you make your political opponents
fight amongst each other and that's
what's happening right now II have
Michelle Obama Hillary Eric Holder all
fighting amongst each other and that
helps the right you know who would not
have apologized Michael a vanetti oh
that's true do you think that there is
something about the the wings especially
on the left wing right now wanting a
fighter somebody's gonna say it like why
would you apologize for that obviously
one you could say you got a laugh out of
the crowd President Trump says lots of
things get last from the crowd and what
does the left say like oh I can't
believe you said that is terrible right
and now we're the right is saying that
about Eric Holder about proportionality
I'm gonna use that fake outrage line
next time I say something he would not
have apologized no he wouldn't he would
have doubled down Greg it's funny the
Democrats debating on whether to take
the high road I don't think they've ever
taken the Harbor accusing an innocent
man of gang rape for about two weeks is
not exactly the I wrote and what is
Scalise get off lot lecturing people
about violence anyway I will say this
before I get it to my seriously I I
actually believe what Holder is saying
because I oh I believe in the principle
that you don't take the worst meaning or
the worst intention of what somebody's
saying I don't believe he was inciting
violence he was he was basically saying
you have to fight harder having said
that accusations of incivility in my
opinion don't bug me at all I think
incivility is actually pretty good
because it reduces the chance for
violence the more if you're in civil
with each other it might mean you might
not punch the thing that bothers me is
the incitement and enabling of a mob so
when you have Netflix employees for
example stalking Kilmeade in order for a
show on Netflix
and then inciting the passengers on the
subway to join in in this orgy of
persecution would you have to look fors
you have to look at people like that
because persecution is like this
contagion it's like when you're in a mob
it spread through repetition and very it
can happen very easily and I think we
need to contrast words again in deeds
what holders saying is words but you got
to look at the deeds and I people are
comparing Donald Trump you know his
words to left-wing deeds I get at Trump
it can be rude his jokes can be mean but
there's no right wing anti-shah or
Occupy Wall Street
there's no right wings police shooting
there's no right wing mobs chasing
people out of restaurants or Broadway
plays and there's no right wing Netflix
employees because nobody who's
right-wing works at Netflix yeah right
so what Holder says something like this
I didn't think he was actually talking
about literally kicking Republicans with
his foot Greg's point is that in the
context of all the other deeds that have
gone on in the last week month year
where there's been violence and threats
and things like that it doesn't add
anything to the conversation in a
positive way well I think it does I
think both Dana and Greg said to you
Jesse that what Democrats want are
people who are going to stand up and
fight for the Democratic brand right now
Republicans control the White House the
Congress and the Supreme Court and
oftentimes they feel like remember that
USA Today piece the president wrote this
week they think he gets away with saying
things that are untrue and nobody's
standing up and say hey this guy is
misleading you Republicans hey where did
you go Republican party come on back
don't need to become trumpian but here's
the thing I'm listening to all you guys
I think wait a second what kind of
one-sided presentation says this is the
guy who was at rallies this week and
he's got the crowd yelling lock her up
not about Hillary it was Diane Feinstein
places to give him credit but at the
same time when Holder says Democrats
need to stand up while he's inside I
just think that's crazy and we can say
that we've said that's kind of you say
there's no shooting oh my gosh these
Scalise was tarrant that was an act of
horror but you got to admit they went
into a pizza parlor in Washington the
other thing though is yes
brought this up and I bring it up we
okay I'll bring up how about
Charlottesville they run over somebody
in Charles Emerson and there are nuts oh
I see when it comes to Republicans we
got to be honest it's a bug in the
system when it comes to the left it's
the system you guys have had the Weather
Underground SLA the Black Panthers the
Manson Family Auntie far will
Republicans have nothing like that you
have white nationalist you have a
Clinton as much as you hate them what do
you think I you know it's interesting
you you both gave holds our the benefit
of the doubt and that's great I probably
would too but he wouldn't give you if
one of you said that you could forget it
it wouldn't have your back at all I
think this all started with the refusal
to accept that Trump had won and it
started with that and people on the Left
said you know what this was this was not
a proper election and they incited
everybody to to say that this election
was not tangible and they should rally
against and it started with Maxine
Waters and I think the difference is
these are leaders these are many leaders
down the Democratic Party you know
people talk to me all the time old Tea
Party rallies you know the signs they
saw Tea Party rallies I don't want to
hear about signs and have that signs of
people at a rally which by the way I
never saw an offensive sign I went to a
million rallies and never saw one I
don't want to hear that compared to
leaders in the Democratic Party holder
Hillary Clinton who could have been
president coming out and saying
outrageous things and good on Michelle
Obama by the way who came out and said
this is not acceptable what's going on
I'm sure Hillary Clinton was not happy
with her but I commend that because I
think when something like this happens
it's it's important for people within
the party itself to stand up to it
so any Democrats that come out and stand
up to this I salute them as well I wish
their public ins would stand for
something outrageous things
many Republicans criticize Donald Trump
when he says something that is not
appropriate we are very willing to say
don't it tweeted that
what a differentiate between what we're
talking about though and I don't want to
litigate political violence here but but
Greg was bringing up a lot of examples
and I was yesterday of left-wing attacks
on Republican officials cabinet members
Trump family members elected officials
there's been violence perpetrated by the
right on the left in the streets and
that's awful and that's random but when
you're going after political leadership
in a democracy that takes it to a higher
level and I think that's the difference
what's what going after political
leadership Bryson Isis threats waiters
chasing them around in the streets on a
political leadership and not something
you know driving into a car or shooting
up a random pizza place that's it I'm
not excusing that I'm saying it's
different categorically what so it's
different if someone stands up and says
hey I disagree with you I think Mitch
McConnell that what you did denying my
car I'm in this airport and I'm going to
let you hear it that's not American
waters approach what's Maxine
chasing people through restaurant Oh
Jason you are so dramatic I thought she
said one on the drum it's okay